had an awful battle the doctor set my
parents down and said my life was
fragile perspective is the game i
guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change sympathy helping fields yeah
that's what i wanted be a patient hello
[Music]
we are [ __ ] back
january 20th 2022
a show that i enjoyed so much during
covid
is now back tea with garyvee it is
awesome to see all of you will jackson i
see you brian lopez i see you in the
comments
katie schaefer
uh great to see you
realtor chris webb is in the building
deandre george josiah on facebook
let's go let's go let's go let's go we
have our guest dustin get in here i need
to feel
your over-the-top massive energy you're
still sitting in the same place yup
you're just sitting in the same place
yep
i don't change a lot
like i could see that we're still
how tell blow everyone's face off ready
how old are you
37
that is [ __ ] crazy yeah
i don't believe it either myself
sometimes
because you look 23
yeah something like that
anyway we are back t with garyvee are
you excited about
this very much
sorry i have a
weird echo going on yes i heard that
i like it
brings some flavor to the table anyway
this is the show where we uh just do
some q a with people
uh live
and uh i enjoy it askgaryvee show's back
that is not live team with garyvee is
back that is live
and it's uh it's fun time so let's um
let's get some peeps
let's get some peeps
hey
hey rob
how's it going gary what's going on
doing
so good thank you yeah welcome to the
show
yeah it's uh thanks for having me um if
you probably remember because you always
remember everything i was with you at
4ds in 2019 fall 2019.
we were ready as a family we was like
all right we're ready blank slate you
said you're an amazing opportunity um
pandemic hit we kind of went half in
and so we we kind of got out of canada
we got down to michigan we realized that
still wasn't what we wanted
and so uh march of 2021 we decided let's
go all in so we played out the thesis we
sold the house we moved down south um
we're renting went all in on tick tock
all in on tick tock
like so many people have heard before it
started going really well for us because
when we moved down here i didn't have a
job so like maybe we could push into
this and uh so it went really well
um and then instagram started building
on the back of that and just recently
youtube's building on the back of that
so since march 21
we're at like 800 million views
um almost i think over 700 000 on tick
tock now instagram and youtube are just
getting rolling now but they're almost
both at 90 000 each uh for follower
subscribers
so and it's been amazing like it is it's
been amazing for us as a family it's
opened up some opportunities right now
it's a very nice little side hustle
um but we're really enjoying it and i
think for as a family where we want to
go
so now we're not just as you preach get
in it you know get in it get in it and
you've been saying this for years but
now we're you know 800 million views not
even a year in we think that okay this
can go from a nice little hobby to maybe
we can actually make this into something
more and so would the strategy change
much and of course i know you keep
putting in the work i mean of course
i know you're going to say that and be
patient
of course but i want to be smart as well
so as we keep doing the work as a small
to medium-sized creator influencer
how can we be smart so that in the next
six months of the next year we can keep
building on this and possibly making a
career out of it
look i mean i think the reality is it
comes down to only two things one
continue to
put out meaningful content in as many
places as possible
um two
try to get
major brands to sponsor
early
and lock you in so
going from a side hustle to something
more meaningful
comes
with the foundation of like can we get
the finances
that allow us to get there right
can you know
and one of the ways to do that is to go
to a
nike or
pepsi or
you know uh
at any walmart any large business
or
not even one of those top five but even
a top five thousand company and say look
you should sponsor our family's content
right and
sponsorship comes in the form of like
actually being able to extract bigger
dollars
maybe even before you own them
meaning even before you're there
somebody could decide to give you five
hundred thousand dollars to buy you know
especially as a family content play like
best buy might just be in the mood to
write you a bigger check you know and so
i think that there's two ways to go
about this one business develop and try
to get macro sponsorship deals that
allow you the finances that you allude
to by going all in
and the other part is the mundane it is
you know
why i've lost some weight here in the
first three weeks of the year if you do
the right things you know they it will
work out and the longer you do them the
longer they work out and the more you
pump out content on youtube shorts and
tick tock and instagram and do you start
a podcast do you do an interactive show
like i'm doing right now do you build a
discord to put your community in there
interact more it is really just
the blocking and talent
tackling that is required to build
something meaningful reading all the
comments right now from all the you know
uh people on youtube and linkedin and
facebook right now
you know
and definitely because i've been in nft
land i'm just flabbergasted by people's
absurd
interest in things happening immediately
so many people are about to lose so much
money in nft land
not because of anything else but their
own short-term greed
and want to make a quick buck
yeah so so that the ford bs the strategy
was seven thousand eight thousand
messages on linkedin um so same thing
um same thing same same thing same thing
connected with as many cmos that you
think
chief marketing officers that you think
make sense that would be interested in
your family and like
you know
which businesses benefit by having
products
yeah or associations with you
yeah
yeah so so if it comes up with your talk
with the cmo of gatorade today we're
available
i love you brother i'm going to try to
get to a bunch of them too okay one more
can i play wildcard real quick so
because i'll make it real real quick
when i was with you my my 15 year old
was 6 11. now he's 17 7 1. and so i know
a lot of people are watching this uh
we're down in the south he's starting to
get on the radar because we came from
canada knowing who he is
and of course i'm his dad he's a special
kid he's starting to get some uh
colleges
what what's his instagram uh so if you
go to thattollfamily.com
then you'll be able to pull everything
else there's a video of carter on there
if you watch that video you can get to
us and all of his links are on there as
well
that's hall family if you're recruiting
a 7-1 beast thanks rob talk to you thank
you take care
i love the wild card dustin you knew he
rob was smart there right he knew he was
going to get me with that you know i'm
trying to get to moore but
he got me yeah he got me all right let's
keep it moving i'm going to bring on
jason next
chase hey gary good to see you very well
thank you
thanks very much for having me on thanks
team i just quickly gary uh my wife and
i run our own fitness studio and i
suppose this time of year we see a lot
of people beginning their own fitness
and health journey and i wanted to speak
to you about yours and
what are your biggest day-to-day changes
that you notice in your life now as
opposed to when maybe it wasn't a
priority for you you know five ten
whatever years ago yeah i'm 46 now i
started at 38 and a half i always make
that joke of how i was going to start at
40 then 39 i was like [ __ ] it start now
so i'm you know i'm almost eight you
know or eight and a half years in um
for me it was soft tissue
jason it was flexibility you know my
left side was broken because of the
liquor store as a kid i tweaked
something and you know my ql
was a lot was so tight that it
completely
really was a struggle um
and
you know i think besides the visual of
being more chiseled and having more
muscle and you know
those kind of things um
you know
i think that
it was really just quality quality of
life around flexibility for me
um
you know i sleep as well then and now
you know my energy levels are the same
like there's no you know there's people
go through different things they all we
all have you know
derek in here just says gary you act
like you have the answers to life he's
he's trolling and being razzing me and
i'm like i really don't i just talk
about the things i
believe in and i know i actually think
the reverse i don't think i know
anything or am special or any better
than anybody and i think that's what
comes down to like a lot of the physical
stuff right like every one of us has
something different
right
for me it was absolutely flexibility
you're catching me in an ironic time i'd
stayed in within a range of 10 or 12
pounds that i wanted to for a long long
long time right and
i kind of have always strategically in
october november been
focused on
getting myself a little tight because i
know
that
you know the holidays are a challenge
with my birthday thanksgiving and then
christmas time
this year i wasn't able to get there
and what that meant was i kind of went
to a number that i didn't want to be at
you know which you know over sharing i
got to 182
in the first point
do you obsess about the number though is
that something i don't i don't at all
but i know what it means it means like
and so
and so in 20 days of this year i'm down
to 166.
because i'm eating
i haven't i haven't been eating i've
been calorie and and i i don't
again in the same way that i'm not
devastated about the weights because
there's water weight there's a million
things in that number that matters same
with when it goes in the reverse
i'm just calorie depleting because i
like fasting and i sometimes just get
into momentum and it's kind of fun i've
had really strong workouts and i know
that i'm not putting enough protein into
it myself in a three week window to
let's say maximize the work i just put
in and i'm not over upset about that
either i just decided in you know these
three weeks i'd like to really kill the
momentum that you know it's that slow
two three you know you could feel
yourself and i was like so you know the
biggest thing for my journey is
education even the way you just ask that
i don't i'm aware that a lot of it's
water weight i know that when i
because i work out seven days a week but
i really don't go like one you know two
of those days are a cardio or a lot of
it is soft tissue work you know it's the
the way i order food or
when i substitute things or is it tea
instead of coffee with oat milk like
it's the education of knowing how to
take care of myself which is almost like
the physical version of what i try to
teach people in business which is as
long as you're educated how to use
tik-tok as long as you're educated that
yes there's a big nft movement but 99
are gonna fail because they're all
[ __ ] like you know it's education
you know i may not love the modern
school system but i believe in education
more than anything kayla's just said
intermittent fasting it's uh just
another way to reduce your calories
kayla don't be
guarding those fads there's so many fads
out there and then yeah there's a
million i just uh
and jason you have to know your your
body right for me right that's correct
for me
fasting has been a part of my life my
whole life
yeah like my whole life long like i used
to not i didn't even know what it was
called fast i was like i just would talk
to my mom and i was just we'll put a
buzzword on it yeah i was like i don't
you know i don't i didn't i didn't eat
today because i wasn't independent
you know so anyway nonetheless thank you
my friend
thank you guys cheers have a great day
cheers
uh next we're going to bring on
tatiana
tatiana
hey gotti how are you i'm very well
tatiana how are you
well i'm super grateful thank you for
the opportunity to to be here means a
lot my heart is like boom boom boom
right now
very soon
um i want to say i'm from peru and right
now i'm in a small
city called trujillo and it's fantastic
because your book right here is in peru
right now and that's my question for
today
i'm a virtual educator and when kovit
came
you told everyone create an account on
tock and make content so i did that
and then i was loose like i didn't know
how to
what
what can be the next step in my
professional career
and i discovered creating content that i
really love learning and teaching other
people
and then i decided to study for a master
in virtual education
because i also discovered that hey
everyone will be study
online not physical
and right now in my small city here in
peru i see all the time academies or
universities college
are
empty and everyone is studying online so
my question is as a virtual educator
what is the best approach i should take
to innovate in education with in web 3
because then you told us what i
remembered like if it were yesterday you
told what is an nft and why i'm buying
this and this and i also have here my
ipad because i love digital drawing and
i create some
gifts like passion panda gifts and
helpful people give you just sometimes
that gifts also on twitter yes and
and well
it's my passion too so
you always teach us in your book to
combine traits yes and i want to combine
education with nfts and web3 so that's
my question
one of the things you can do is you can
start an education course where after
the people complete the course they get
an nft it's their diploma
you can go and find some emerging
artists to design these diplomas
somebody might pay for a course
but when they're done they get a diploma
from an emerging artist and then maybe
four years later and it doesn't have to
actually be the diploma it's just a
piece of nfp as like a diploma but it's
a piece of art a collectible
one of those artists a young lady from
peru a guy from britain you know a guy
from
nigeria that person may go on to become
famous or somewhat famous so now all of
a sudden somebody pays 500
a thousand dollars for a course they get
their education they're given a diploma
but instead of a piece of paper or an
internet email receipt they get
a nft
you as the person at the top spend a lot
of time trying to find some emerging
artists that you really believe in but
they're still emerging so for a very low
cost they make this art
17 years later that person becomes
people or ex copy or the founder of
world of women and all of a sudden this
person says wait a minute my diplomas
were four thousand dollars what's going
on here i don't think people understand
how many things are going to be
happening with nfts i just made that up
on the spot for you that is an actually
strong idea i think receipts diplomas
affirmations that come in email form or
paper form today
can be flipped on their head innovated
on
and created as nice pieces of
collectible arts that support emerging
artists so as the organization now not
only are you giving your student
something that may be
not likely but maybe has some value in
the future but on the flip side you also
give the artist
the royalties or split the royalties
with them so now you sold the course for
100 bucks a thousand bucks a million
bucks whatever it is
but now you're 50 50 partners with the
artist on the royalties
that artist goes on to have a good
career and that person sells their
diploma for three thousand dollars you
know all of a sudden if you put a ten
percent royalty on that you and the
artist just got 150 dollars in ethereum
or solana or wherever you put it on
there's a lot more coming with nfts
right now everyone
is thinking about it a specific way adam
says use the nft to the course a lot of
people are thinking that right a lot of
people are like buy this nft gives you
that people are seeing that my
conference ticket other things people
get that i think it's the innovations
the after the fact here's your
affirmation that something happened i'm
giving you this
a receipt from an internet company who
wants that doesn't mean anything but in
the form of a potential collectible
fascinating and definitely in the form
of a diploma very fascinating that's my
innovation
that's great i will do it just i believe
you give me some time and i will show
you email me
see you bye-bye love you bye-bye
uh next gonna bring on joseph this is
the one from twitter that you're like
get this guy on
well i'm excited i don't remember i i
you know
you clearly you got me excited clearly
joseph how are you good good so i
discovered you in 2020 first episode of
tea with gary vee really a full circle
moment yeah so much gratitude speaking
of which everybody if you're on right
now please share the link that you have
on twitter on facebook share this share
on linkedin let's let's have some more
people discover this is a great
community i love being a part of it go
ahead my friend yeah so a little bit of
a backstory i started playing music when
i was 11. became obsessed with it
started playing seven eight hours a day
that passion led me to go to berkeley
college of music graduated from there um
in 2015 i started creating custom music
for a personal ads tv a year later my
music got on to keeping up with the
kardashians since then it's been on many
networks abc nickelodeon cbs uh all the
three-letter tv networks i've done music
for podcasts for jeff maro from food
network so multiple
episodes of that um on the side i teach
music privately and i mentor up and
coming songwriters so my question for
you is i want to go more on the offense
finding clients for custom music
and i know i need to be more consistent
with social media but if you were me how
would you find new clients that help
generate revenue consistently in an
industry that's more typically one-off
licensing
um by being more consistent with content
on social media
good answer
the reason i just did that is i want
everybody to replay what just happened
if you even there's something very
fascinating about
either needing affirmation from somebody
that you admire
uh repeating something to oneself
you know the fact that you know the
answer and you stated it in your
question
hey gary and now i know i need to stay
consistent one more thing
right
that moment you and i just had is the
single most important moment
like i want my team to cut that i'm
going to put it on instagram and tick
tock
it is the most important moment my
friend
i
am wildly simple
i say my stuff i say it over and over
again but people don't hear it because
they don't want to do the thing
that i'm saying it's funny that there
was a fitness guy on right like
everybody knows how to get into better
shape it is eat healthy and cleaner
right
and put in work in the gym literally
that's it but we will [ __ ] inject
implants into our ass drink ciders and
vinegars [ __ ] take weird ass pills
that we have no idea what the [ __ ]
they're about
i
say every day right now that 98 to 99 of
nfts are going to zero
nobody hears it they're by they're just
looking to make two thousand bucks on a
snail with a [ __ ]
liquor pipe in its mouth like like
nobody here like i can i will say it
nine thousand times and when the market
does crash everyone's gonna be like gary
and i'm like i [ __ ] said 99 of this
shit's going to zero every [ __ ] day i
have sat here for 15 years saying if you
make content
consistently at
scale on the platforms that people are
paying attention to for you
youtube shorts
tick tock
instagram it's just
massively important if you follow what i
wrote in the thank you economy
a hundred years ago if you reply to
everybody that's talking about music
jingles and music on twitter and just
join the conversation literally search
you know music and like jingles and like
you know whatever you know what you know
your terms to your business
and you just sit there for two hours and
say hey i know something about that
you're using the wrong key or like
bringing value not even saying like hire
me hire me you know that's why i wrote a
book called jab jab jab right hook give
value give value give value and then say
hey by the way i do this for a living
linkedin is an incredible place for you
incredible i talked about linkedin at
nausea on this platform and have
continued to talk about it how much
linkedin content are you making i'll
save you time none
right
i post about three times a week on
linkedin so i need to be posting not bad
not bad no listen honestly i'm happier
about that that's that's a great number
for you i really thought it was gonna be
zero
but but
but you know like
you know it's kind of like push-ups like
13 is better than three
and then the question becomes what do
you post and for me it's like
you know posting things like
here's how i think about providing the
most value when i write music for
someone and then a manifesto
which gives me an insight on the other
side of vayner look i run [ __ ]
vaynerx we want to buy music all the
time
if i see that in my screen and this
happens to me all the time if i see that
in the stream i just hit the link and
send it to our music rights buyer
this is just very important right like
when you've given me the answer to my
question
in the question like you just did
then you [ __ ] know what to do
find a way to make it more fun for you
so that you can [ __ ]
do more of it
perfect most of the people that i
exposed to on social media are musicians
and songwriters so they're not typically
the clients that i would go to let me
teach you something that's going to help
a lot of people here thank you for
saying that
the way i think about things is making
content
that
the audience that i'm exposed to
that is forwardable
to the person i want to get to let me
give you an example
i put out a lot of content around the
mindset of parents
really pushing college agenda on kids
without really looking at their kid
i make the content specific to knowing
the kind of thing that the kid that
consumes it would share to their parent
when i make the content i'm thinking yes
kid you're going to see this but i'm
going to make it in a way that's going
to make you
share it
to your parent
that's very different so the content
isn't like hey kids parents suck right
yeah no no
it's it's intricate so that it brings
value to the pa i'm making it for the
parent
but i'm making it in a way that i know
the kids is going to be the one that
sees it and will forward it to the
parent and the content will not make the
parents say [ __ ] this guy even though
usually they do say that because there's
such a big ideology of college
i need you to know that okay i have
music people in front of me but i'm
gonna make this piece of content for
them
with the thought that they may be the
gateway to bring me exposure to who i'm
trying to get to
so valuable thank you so much you see
what i'm doing there it's your uh i'll
give you an example i've vaynermedia has
made content that's trying to reach 60
year old dads and we've made tick tocks
that we know 14 year old daughters are
gonna see and share it with their dad
there's a lot more strategy to the [ __ ]
i do than people realize that's an
insight to it right there
that's beautiful one more question for
you gary real fast which vayner company
is hiring music composers and where can
i send my credentials send it send it to
gary at vaynermedia.com i'll take care
of it i appreciate you see that gary
thank you can't wait
next we're gonna have miles
how's it going gary miles what's good
it's crazy to be on here i've been a
long time listener so uh really happy to
be on the show thank you yeah i
appreciate it you'll love to hear this
first i was lucky enough to get a koala
from the book games drop dropped it like
you you got like
holy [ __ ] yeah you got a key no koala
yeah i'm pumped it's a
bubble gum background marble frame but
i'm excited
[Music]
yeah good one bro did you uh
and you've taken note obviously of the
date on the briefcase and the whole
night yeah i've taken note i'm you know
i have the
you know you go through in your head
what you think it can be so i have some
theories up there but um i'm excited for
all of it i'm glad you're gonna hold on
to it or do you need the money no i'm
gonna hold on to it i'm i'm lucky enough
to be able to do that right now
to your point on like 99 of these nfts
you know going to zero or however you
say it um
you know i i couldn't be right there
more in that thinking is that
um long term you gotta find founders and
executors that can actually build out
every internet stock in 98 99 and 2000
was overpriced but sitting there was
jeff bezos and he got hammered his
[ __ ] stock got destroyed destroyed in
that but he sat there and he's like cool
i'm just going to keep navigating the
same for me right like if all the
friends which listen if there's a if and
i think there will be but i've been
wrong many times if there's an nft crash
overall a reca it's a correction
yeah you know
it's a correction it's not a elimination
you know and v friends go down i'm just
sitting there like okay it's time to
like you know i've been here before 9 11
took
crushed wine library 911 all our
business was wall street 911 crushed
wine library 2008 economic credit we had
tens of millions of dollars on wine
pre-sales
lehman brothers crashes we get
eight trillion cancellations it crushed
us
it crushed us
coved
like i [ __ ] have been here like i've
done this [ __ ] and so i know how to get
through
dog [ __ ]
and there are a small percentage of
operators that know
well i think that's the the main concern
is you see all these nft projects not to
get caught up on this because i have a
separate question but you see these
projects and you wonder well who are the
people that are leading this thing and
what is the value that they're going to
provide long term
by the way that happens in startup land
all the time
i pass on most startup pitches i look at
right
and 99 of the time those companies go
out of business
the people that lose money in that
scenario are the investors yeah what i'm
worried about is the people are going to
lose money this time are the buyers of
these
and i don't think a lot of them
understand how high risk this all is
yeah absolutely well um i'll get into my
question i'd like to give a little bit
of context first so my brother and i own
and operate a small manufacturing
company in new orleans uh called boyle
boss currently we have two niche
consumer products they're very specific
to boiling seafood so they help with the
boiling secrets yeah so like think like
big crawfish i get it i know that
culture yeah exactly so in about a month
or two we're going to hopefully have our
third product on the market which we're
really excited about my brother's been
working super hard on that product
development um
and so my question is we have a small
team right now just three people and
what i'm focused on now is building out
the systems and processes and generally
just trying to get organized to better
cope with the anticipated volume
obviously as you know there's a ton that
goes on behind the scenes to get a
product out the door it's like i i did
not appreciate it until i i started this
about a year ago
yeah it's real stuff and it's it's been
a challenge but that's something i've
been impressed with is your ability to
go and actually execute the operations
yeah i'm an op you know it's so funny
like when everyone's like he's a
motivational speaker he's an influencer
he's i'm like [ __ ] i'm an
operator yeah well well that and i
honestly that's always like when i'm
when i listen to your podcast i'm like i
wish there was more conversations about
the behind the scenes operations you
know i'll take i'll take note of that my
friend i will really i really think
you're right and i think i need to you
know t does it a little bit
like
you know i talk a lot about it from the
hr side right 12 and a half has really
gone there
um but it is you know and you know this
finding a way to communicate operations
and content is challenging it is
meetings and decisions
meetings and decisions meetings
yeah it's like like and a lot of times
like it's like you know but it's just
meetings and decisions it's like
do we open another office yes no do we
innovate a new division yes no do we
put more money into analytics or
strategy department you know like
there's a lot of that kind of stuff yeah
and so i so i guess just to get to the
actual question i was hoping you could
talk a little bit more about your
experience tactically in the early days
with building out processes delegating
work um and generally just being able to
free yourself and set your employees up
for success because i think that's the
part where we're sort of well you're not
there yet yeah like you know when when
vaynermedia was less than 15 people for
the first two years i didn't have to
think about that [ __ ]
i just did everything
yeah who the [ __ ] you delegating to
you've got three of you
right yeah well so i i get i guess the
ch are you more talking about maximizing
the efficiency of your time when there's
only three of you i think that's more of
what that is we're actually
manufacturing all the products like
right now i did hire somebody in
february who's been awesome and he's
helping with production on one of the
product lines i'm doing all the
production on the other product line and
so it's really maximizing the efficiency
um
and you know as we our goal is to scale
via coming up with totally new to world
products so we have patents on our
current products but we won't just keep
pumping out new products
you want to yeah we want to why
um
we love the you know truths
we love the process of inventing right
and coming out with stuff well good i
mean
one thing that i like opening businesses
i like doing 100 things
one thing you have to do mentally is
understand that if that's what you love
you will drop the ball
yeah
if you're going to invent 17 things
like 12 things are gonna get [ __ ]
and as long as you understand that
you'll actually not stress
on things that don't matter i
am a
voracious
entrepreneur
and have a
voracious need to open up companies
i have to then also understand that
vayner live vayner sampling and many
other veiners that nobody hears about
here failed
because when you're doing 39 things
that's what's going to happen those
divisions failed with within vaynermedia
right i tried to do small business stuff
before then finally sasha worked
but
you know somebody says focus on one
product first susan that works for her
that's that's good for susan that's not
good for you and your brother and you
shouldn't because you know that you and
how do i know this because you said just
now in a way that landed for me
you know
we just enjoy the process of inventing
and i think people don't understand what
we should all be doing out here
is enjoying it
more so than maximizing every dollar
there are people who love their business
at three million a year and then think
they need to grow and go to four million
but they had to hire this and they had
to do this and now they hate it
and i'm like why didn't you just stay at
three and be [ __ ] happy as [ __ ] yeah
i don't think everything i'm doing is
always gonna be the best money maker or
success in the short term
but if i don't live my truth and
continue to innovate every day
well then i'm not going to be happy and
then none of the businesses are going to
work
vaynermedia is successful because i do
do garyvee vaynermedia is successful
because i do help my dad with his wine
stuff vaynermedia is successful because
befriends exist i need everything
to make me happy thus the things that
have clicked will work
too many people so for you
it's hard to prioritize because you're
[ __ ] inventing so many products
but the good thing is you're actually
winning because you understand that you
guys love the process of inventing and
though susan is right for herself and
many others and really even logically
right
she's not right for you two
you two
would rather enjoy and you're so damn
young
that you should only do the things that
actually bring you the most happiness
because that will actually make you win
it's okay on paper that it doesn't work
for others the reason bus levine just
said this is exactly what i need to hear
this is a massive common problem that
most people haven't dissected the way
i'm talking about it right now well and
you know i don't want to keep going too
long because i know you've got to go no
this is a i want to stay here this is
important yeah i think this will help
people too because i don't think we
really struggle with
um
with you know not judging ourselves on
dropping balls you know i think when you
talk about starting a manufacturing
company when you when you do come up
with a product and you buy all the you
have all the overhead and machines and
inventory like you know you got to see
that one through right and you have yeah
yeah like you have to see that through
and you have to create in my opinion
systems and processes to to hopefully
allow that to run so you can move on to
the next one and so i think that's where
we've struggled to like get it organized
you you you haven't struggled your
company's too young yeah you're creating
an ideology of like we should be here
how long has the company been existing
it's been three years it's five minutes
you know that's five seconds right yeah
it's it doesn't feel like it but i know
yeah it's five seconds like you've and
you've launched two products yes we have
two products at right now and then um
we'll have a third coming and you're
profitable
uh yeah yeah
do you understand how [ __ ] amazing
yeah [ __ ] hardly you didn't go out of
business most people are out of business
in three years right and hardly is
you're [ __ ] profitable
right
yeah no you're right you're right like
like cool i'm very thrilled that you're
ambitious and you're you're you'd like
it we all want to be better and do
better
but
the good news is you're not struggling
with it you just haven't gotten to it
yep
yep
you just haven't gotten to it you're not
struggling with it you [ __ ] have been
doing too many things you're like
successfully entrepreneuring
yeah well you know i'll give credit to
my brother because he he really started
this thing um from the ground up and i
think i've so since i graduated last
year i joined in and now it's been you
know how can we continue to grow and
scale and free up more of our time can i
give can can i give you a huge piece of
advice
please
never ever
ever
choose money
or your own pride and ego
over your brother
yep
yeah
you were grabbed to go through a thing
where you know money is binary some
people just love it so much that they're
willing to hurt their relationship with
their family and that's very challenging
it's grounded in a lot of insecurity but
it is what it is and like
it's kind of an easy one the second one
is harder
the need to say bro i did that you did
this this kind of like feeling of
competitive spirit of like no i am
yo bro you came up with the invention
but that marketing campaign i did on
tick tock [ __ ] that's why and
to have the humility the reason i
successfully worked with my dad and my
brother was
it was the humility
for me at the end of the day as much as
i was like i'm the guy
what really at the end of the day
mattered was not choosing my own
feelings
of need of like validation and money
never at the end of the day sure in
little rifts but in real life
never choosing that over the love of my
brother and dad is the greatest single
business accomplishment of my life and
it's not
even close
i appreciate you saying that yeah you
guys are really young
you're hungry you're ambitious you're
doing it together you're this is going
to be the best years of your life you
were going to remember these days more
than anything yep
it can go sour really fast
if you do not
deploy that humility and choose it
because you love your brother
got it
yep i appreciate it gary thank you my
friend thank you
thank you
up next we're gonna have derrick
hey gary hey how are you
good
um so
i was wondering how do you balance you
know posting on social media to build
your brand while you're still working in
a company because most companies would
view you know you posting on social
media all day as a negative and not
doing your job so how do you kind of
balance those two things
by picking a job that has good managers
and leaders that don't see it that way
yeah
you know you understand businesses are
just made up of people
like for example
we don't even have a system to watch
what our people are doing
i trust my people
and i want good for them i want them to
be productive
but i want them to be happy and if it
makes them happy to tweet all day in
between meetings mazel tov
my father
wants to ban cell phones in the liquor
store
because if somebody checks their text
for one second
to see if their mom or if they're if
their bus is on time my dad loses his
mind
that's not my time two very different
men me and my dad
there's
no chance you're tweeting all day
with pops
you can [ __ ] make unlimited content
with me and that's the world there's a
bunch of sasha's there's a bunch of
gary's
you if you want to do what you just said
you better work for a [ __ ] gary
and if you don't
right now and it means so much to you to
post well then you should start looking
for another job if you're good then
you're good but that is it it is that
simple
i like it yeah because i i i want to
start being able to you know before i
started listening to your content i
wasn't aware of the importance of
building your brand you know on social
media it was more of you know while i'm
at work while i'm at co-workers friends
you know building my brand in person
with people that i interact with every
day but it's more
once i started listening to what what
you talk about it's like okay if if i do
one day want to start my own business
which i do
um
starting to build that process but you
know i kind of struggled with i didn't
want to do that all the time while i'm
still working at you know a company and
look you also have to be respectful
right you know like doing the right
thing is always the right thing if
you're getting paid and you're quietly
like not working we have some employees
that are trying to be very clever at
vayner
and my big thing is like hey i laugh
because i'm like do they think they're
tricking me
b
you know i just want to
say to them like hey man like do it hang
out like like doing the right thing is
important like
you know like
you will lose in the end when you don't
do the right things and so i think you
know finding the right balance on that
is very important you know
yeah
you know but on the flip side i tell a
lot of my business friends i'm like yo
why are you mad at that person you're
[ __ ] emailing them at all hours of
the night
right these people are supposed to work
nine to five nine to six like you're
[ __ ] hitting them at seven and eight
and nine and ten and eleven and six like
so like don't be on a [ __ ] pedestal
business owner like your person might
have yes spent seven minutes
you might be on the clock right now and
here we are fine but what about at 8 30
when you email them and they have to do
something for 15 minutes like people are
you act like people keeping score on
some [ __ ] like
your employees are your family
yeah and as a business owner if you
don't see it that way you've already
lost
yeah no that's great
awesome
appreciate it
all right we got next we're gonna have
chase
chase
gary
thanks for having me on man really good
to talk to you
i'm uh
ogb friend um been following you for a
long time
um just just really excited to be on um
i took
you know i just want to say i appreciate
truly appreciate
all of the
info
and documentation y'all put out prior to
v friends launching back in may that was
big chase you know if you ask me the
thing i'm most proud of with vfriends
it's not even that it's done great and
it will and like
as long as i am healthy the friends is
going to really win because i'm a very
capable entrepreneur
um
but the thing i'm more proud of is
through that education and we did it so
hard
so heavy months
people learned
they learned how to get a metamask they
learned what a seat phrase was they
learned the theory some people while
they were waiting for v friends minted
board ape because i was delayed 4.0 like
like such great things happened people
learned i'm proud of that
yeah i'm i'm 100 in that group i mean
honestly if you and your team hadn't put
that out
i i wouldn't have jumped into your
project um
i bought five ethereum back in 2018
put all of it into your project
and
got two rares and a spec on the floor
and uh
best best financial move i've ever made
have you sold any of them absolutely not
and i don't plan to for a very long time
wow i'm so humbled good for you brother
thank you thank you so much my question
um is more on the personal side of
things
with the countless things that you have
going on in your professional life how
do you stay balanced
and make sure that you're giving your
wife and kids the attention that they
deserve
um communication effort
you know priority like you know
people see so much from me
but like i don't think they really
realize
they don't see anything
i'm very prolific in my content creation
why
i allocate an hour like this get in with
my community get these vibes going right
this is nice like this is an amazing
morning it's been a lot of good content
i'm reading the chat i feel so connected
to everybody but you know this that
[ __ ] last thing with that kid from
new orleans that thing is going to be
viewed a billion times like i'm going to
chop the [ __ ] out of that right it's
huge and so then i'm going to penetrate
on linkedin for family business and on
tick-tock for one little part of it and
this you know and and and it feels like
i did a fulsome full send podcast you do
that for an hour but then there's like
[ __ ] ungodly amounts of content out
of it so and i and i work and i work
hard and i really enjoy it but like
there's way more hours in my life that
are going on that nobody sees nobody
knows anything about
and i keep it that way
and it's kind of easy to be honest it's
like i don't value
anything more than people that i love
and
why would i
why would i
not prioritize that i don't need the
outside validation of wealth creation or
headlines or positive reinforcement from
social media it's all lovely it's all a
byproduct what i need
is to spend time with the people i love
and i need to do the thing i love and
the thing i love to do is be an
entrepreneur but i was loving this [ __ ]
at 26
at wine library
working for my dad
the same exact way
i feel right now
i felt at 28
the same because for me it's just
playing tennis
right for me business is sports
for me at 28 i was playing tennis for me
at 46 i'm playing tennis now i'm better
at tennis
people know who i am now i'm more
of like a famous tennis player
but at the end of the day
i don't need the selfies in the streets
i don't need people leaving a goat emoji
it's also why i'm comfortable when
people are like you [ __ ] suck you're
full of [ __ ]
i don't because i don't need the good i
don't need the bad and i'm just kind of
in my
zone and i'm just playing tennis out
here
right and so because those are the only
two things i focus on it's actually very
easy
to balance because i think when you do
need the accolades when you do need the
million dollars to buy a mercedes to
show them i'm going to show you that i'm
successful i'm insecure i'm going to
show you then you start losing track of
your time with the people you love
because you're obsessed with the
negativeness of the game
100
totally agree
thank you i appreciate the uh the alpha
um
really looking forward to meeting you in
person at vcon in may i think vcon is
going to be one of the greatest weekends
of my life
i am so obsessed
with meeting every single person we are
like we back to operations we are in
countless meetings tracking how we're
going to do the panels how we're gonna
do the keynotes i'm like trying to
figure out like i need to do like a
selfie booth it's like a kissing booth
but like this is that's how i can get a
lot of people but we can't interrupt
with that keynote so when are we like
it's real [ __ ] out here for me yeah yeah
a lot of moving parts but um it's going
to be an epic week and weekend and the
best part is i don't even feel like i
need to be kind of mickey mouse or walt
disney i think the community is so
[ __ ] fired up to see each other
like i can't i can't it's going to be
like summer camp right like especially
become 2 v con 3
like
people are family
absolutely yeah sharing the same rarity
type or sharing the same character it's
going to be unbelievable yeah you're the
community that's being built is is
insane i mean there's so many of us that
hop on a clubhouse channel every morning
or afternoon or evening and it's the
best so many things coming from it man
it's uh the relationships in themselves
are are well worth the ticket
i agree thank you my friend thank you
take care
all right next we're going to have on
osman osmond sorry if i pronounced it
wrong hey gary how's it going osman how
are you not too bad not too bad you got
my name right thank you for that of
course i know some awesome ones um
so i'm from toronto canada um i have a
small reception by the way literally
literally said it last night over dinner
i think my favorite city besides new
york city
there we go you know i saw that louis
toronto nft i'm pretty sure vikan's
coming here soon
there's a reason
that st louis and toronto is an nft in
france um so uh gary for my question i
have a
small recycling brokerage we sell and
export paper and plastics um so right
now i'm the first sales guy i'm doing
everything um
and my question was how do i bring on
the first employee number one to do more
sales because the brokerage
and allow that person to also help the
business but also grow themselves
because there's not like you have a
culture yet it's just it's employee
number one
there's some people that don't need
all that in place there's a lot of
people that grow more by being employed
one two seven nine and fifteen
then
every employee that was in the first
hundred employees at vayner had more
growth than every employee that comes
into vayner today even though we have
the i have systems that i'm so proud of
because
you're in the trenches early you're
learning through osmosis
okay
okay i got that but now in a brokerage
environment because i guess in vayner
there's projects
right they're they're they're sort of
just work on this project work on this
thing it's different but in a brokerage
where it's like they're going to be
actively looking for sales and looking
for clients
we're not necessarily working together
we're working independently that's right
so um is it the same thing just allow
them to just go themselves of course
well no i mean
look
sales
yes and no sales
go sales is real life
there's no hiding
so that's why i love it so much
you can't make pretend in sales
okay
right it is what it is so of course one
of the ways to grow is to let them sink
and swim of course
but the osmosis comes in different ways
you're going to be interacting with them
as you're going to be talking to them
of course and so you're going to be
analyzing
they'll be talking you'll be thinking
and you say hey but maybe you want to
try to start with this on the opening
sentence or did you tell them about that
or hey did you follow up and have an in
person or whatever it might be
so you're doing both it's like raising
a capable child a capable child needs
both
you know right now there's so many
people that are over parenting their
kids and putting them into a bubble
making all their decisions taking care
of everything for them of course they
can't do [ __ ] at 22.
right
same with sales
you've got to create a framework and be
a support system but you can't [ __ ]
you got to let them live
you've got to let them win and lose on
their own sales ability i think the
thing you look for when you hire the
first person is have they lived in that
environment i would hire somebody who's
already been
on a sales team where they were one of
just two or three people because they've
tasted it already
or
you go with your gut intuition and you
can see the [ __ ] flame in her or his
eyes
and you give him an at-bat
sink and swim
things love that
sink or swim but you don't actually let
them sink you jump in the pool and save
them
but you know you can't teach your kid
swimming by just holding them the whole
time
and you can't teach sales without
letting them
do it
synchro swim got it um yeah appreciate
that and uh once again again i think
some guys mentioned before uh og uh we
friend owner uh thank you for educating
the community um you know 2020 is a bad
year directing everybody
but i think buying in too early you know
i think i'm now six figures up
uh so appreciate that going to be a v
con minneapolis can't wait thank you so
much thanks jasmine
and finally we have charles
oh my god nice hat charles thank you
very much thank you very much good
morning gary
uh sorry i'm kind of freaking out
nothing to freak out about my friends
but um before i
ask my question i just want to give a
huge huge shout out to the v friends
community um
like so many of others have said today
i'm
one more example of one of the
success stories that's come out of the v
friends drop and um
you know i've followed your content for
since about 2018 and um
yeah i can i can definitely say i'm one
of those people who's had their lives
completely fundamentally changed from
your content and just a huge thank you
to you
and um thank you charles means a lot to
me
anyway um so
for my question i'm kind of currently
living through my
37 things you know um
i've been kind of in business for myself
since
before covid
and just done it through
100 different you know selling products
flipping this that you know and i
definitely
was able to get a huge win off of the v
friends i owned two
um
one of them was actually gifted to me a
very rare uh driven dragon wow which i'm
still like in shock that that ever
happened but um
yeah my question is uh some of the best
communication practices to implement
more kind candor into your day-to-day
interactions um especially in business
and professionally like how do you you
know i i struggled with this my whole
life i talked about in the book i was
not good at candor i was not good at
saying hey susan i don't like this
yeah
um
then i then i put the word kind in front
of it and it made it easier for me
i think for all of us that struggle with
candor
um
the reality is is we have to find a way
for us to be comfortable with
professional kind appropriate
confrontation
you know like we're avoiding
confrontation either in our own
insecurities or for me it was actually
and i don't love
this but it's true i had a level of ego
which i'm really proud that i'm mainly
confidence
and not ego but in as i broke it down
and really worked through it i realized
that i thought this person wasn't good
at their job because my my com my issue
with candor has always been employees
nobody else because i love them so much
i'm in family life
and i took this weird tack that okay now
i know they're not great
but they're not great so
out there in the real world they're
gonna really do bad so they're better
off with me and it was almost like this
you know really like
very it seemed like a good thing but
it was like built in my own
ego like that i would be a better home
for them than somewhere else and
it it led to over 20 years the only
relationships that i have that are not
positive
are the ones that i wasn't able to
deploy enough candor to
and then would surprise them when we
would fire them
and it's really unfortunate something i
regret and it's something i've been
really working hard on and it's been
going a lot better for me trials in the
last
two years and what i could tell you is
for me it was when i decided it was kind
candor and with that all of a sudden i
could really just get there and i just
realized i was ready at 44 to get there
um
and so for you you just have to figure
out how you can get there to actually
tell somebody what you actually think
yeah um
i have to say like
especially in business some you know
i've started
many
different projects since i've turned 20
and um i've always ended up doing excuse
me
excuse me for one second oh i love where
you're about to go robin says kind
candor equals constructive criticism
yes but i think constructive criticism
what i try to tell people is like the
word criticism
in itself is already like you know like
when you leave somebody with candor like
you know when you leave candor
a lot of people go with fear they're
scared
when you're done talking and they're
looking for a new job or they're crying
at home like
you know you've got to find a way to be
able to make somebody feel good or at
least neutral
while understanding and the problem is
when people hear constructive criticism
they hear the criticism part and like i
don't think people know how to deliver
feedback a lot and that's why the word
kind i think really lands because kind
is very distinct kind candor it's kind
like but it's candor and and i really
i really you know back to your point
and i have this too when you're starting
things with friends and family it's
really hard to tell them the truth
like i've become family with my
employees but i've had family and
friends and sometimes
[Music]
yeah i
i'm actually in the process of starting
a business with my girlfriend right now
so
it's it's like it's similar it's the top
thing on my mind
i think you over communicate now hey
baby
i'm really i'm really worried about this
[ __ ] we're going into this no me this is
be vulnerable be naked you know she's
already seen you naked so you're good
you know like
be naked right like like i'm very
worried about this i'm not good at this
per se
and you're my girl
i'm gonna probably start getting
resentment then i may crack and like you
know you gotta really talk about it up
front
so that she knows what's happening as
well uh but then like i said to the
younger brother combo earlier just love
her more than the business
thank you i really appreciate that
and i just want to give a couple of
specific shout outs to the v friends uh
shout out corso shout out post
shout out brick shout out kelly shout
out kali bud shout out josh and shout
out nft jack
they've been my homies since like day
one it was awesome
and uh anyway i really appreciate it
love you guys wrapping up see you later
see you
i'll see you there thank you my friend
good job dust you guys found a lot of
good peeps
oh that was all seth
seth big shout out to you brother i
don't know if you're behind the scenes
right now or not but
big big shout out
um
i hope everybody's super well i see all
of you in the comments i love you very
much thank you for watching the show
t with garyvee is back we'll try to do
it as much as i can
uh full disclosure i am deep in series
two v friends right now dustin's even
shaking his head because he's on the
such a key part of my content team he
knows i'm not even posting content to my
normal volume i'm deeply deep in the
cocoon right now um and i uh
i uh
really really really just i'm so
grateful for this community i hope
everybody's super well i wish you
nothing but the best i love you
go love yourself we'll see you next time